hi there I'm Chris Bryan I'm the
creative director for South Park Digital
Studios I was lien animator and
supervising animator for almost 11 years
and today I'm going to be walking you
around the South Park 20 experience at
the Paley Center in Beverly Hills in Los
Angeles the 20 most popular moments and
South Park fandoms we wanted to let
people feel like they were part of the
episode and the whole idea with every
moment that we did is that if you take
the photo from the right angle looks
like you're actually inside one of the
scenes from the series this moment is
probably one of our more infamous it's
the introduction of the character
lemmiwinks this is the scene where
lemmiwinks has been put into mr. slave's
intestines and meets all these
fantastical creatures and actually crawl
in and get down on your hands and knees
and be right there with the frog print
this is definitely one of my favorites
in the exhibit where we are right now is
Randy on his balls this is probably top
three fan favorites of all time the
episode where Randy wants to get medical
marijuana so he gives himself testicular
cancer so fans can actually hop on and
put themselves into that scene where all
the guys are hopping down South Park
Avenue this is good times with weapons
where the kids purchase these ninja
weapons and they invent these personas
for themselves
the fans love this episode and it seems
like a really natural place to build
these out so that you could see the big
proportions of what the kids would be
and how they would imagine themselves
this moment is from the season 8 episode
woodland critter Christmas this is one
of the episodes that Matt and Trey have
talked a lot about that they didn't
really know what to do and the only idea
that they had was blood orgy when we
were working on this episode they were
giving us these animals to animate and I
was one of those things where everybody
was saying well what is this actually
about and it just became this great
thing where the story goes off the rails
this moment is around the episode Scott
tenorman must die this is probably the
most popular episode and in the history
of South Park the episode where Cartman
gets Scott tenorman by having this chili
cook-off and Cartman serves Scott his
own parents so here we are with PC
principal and Topher PC principal was
just introduced last season but he's
become a popular enough to be in here
with pieces like the anal probe you know
anal probe was 19 seasons ago so it's
really great to see fans gravitating
towards the history of South Park but
the
the newer pieces as well